this is our only chance
we have to take it
[Music]
we need kong the world needs him
what's up everybody carlos here you made
it to the end of the week
congratulations there are no spoilers
in this nerd alert just a whole lot of
great nerdy news i'm
very excited to talk about so let's get
to it
we're gonna kick things off with thor
love and thunder news featuring
idris elba check out what he said to us
in a recent e.t canada interview
i'm in um sydney sydney australia man
i'm actually making a movie where
um i don't wanna i can't say too much
about it but i have to stay fit for this
film
so we do know that thor love and thunder
started filming in sydney recently tesla
thompson is there
matt damon is there fun and with idris
confirming that he's there does that
mean
that heimdall is back from the dead
probably yes because death
means nothing in the mcu
and we love it that way
in movie news my nine-year-old is going
to be very excited about actress tikka
sumter has confirmed that sonic the
hedgehog 2 will begin filming in march
in both vancouver and hawaii the first
movie
a lot better than a lot of us expected
it to be i think
you're right it was lame gift shop was
cool though
but how amazing would it be if the
filmmakers showed us like a big reveal
of the design of like knuckles and it
was terrible and everybody hated it
that would be i mean i would lowkey love
that
[Music]
next up if you're into the idea of
having actual depth
in your video game movie adaptations
well this one might be for you
misha green the show runner for
lovecraft country has signed on to be
both writer and director
of the upcoming tomb raider sequel
starring alicia vikander
she even tweeted this to prove her love
for the tomb raider franchise
[Music]
very excited to see what she'll do with
it but if you can't wait for a great two
meter story
then just go play rise and shadow of the
tomb raider misha's right
she's totally right
[Music]
[Applause]
so maybe the biggest movie news of the
week goes to godzilla
versus kong the trailer dropped at the
beginning of the week and the world went
crazy
everyone's like yes could finally see
these two kaiju
battle it out head to head on march 26th
except it's not gonna be march 26
because a couple days later they were
like
no no no it's pushed back to march 31st
i don't care how many demons he's and
how many hells
he's never fought us not us united
there is speculation however that that
march 26 spot is going to zack snyder's
justice league
a film that fans have been waiting years
for
and that'll be pretty cool you know like
two big movies on back-to-back weekends
why not
a big week for warner brothers films as
they showed off a trailer of their hbo
max
same day premieres featuring a lot of
movies i'm very excited for dune
we got space jam a new legacy mortal
kombat and the suicide squad
with a clip of once again idris elba
this time talking to
absolutely nobody at all no one likes to
show off
unless what they're showing off is dope
as [ __ ] and finally episode 4 of wand
division drop on disney plus
today if you saw the preview teaser
thing they did yesterday
um and you'll know that this is the
episode where everything changes we're
not gonna talk about it in this
particular video though we do a deep
dive into every episode of wand division
in a separate little nerd alert series
so you can keep your eyes open for that
and you know that's that's it for me and
when i say that's it i mean that's
all the energy i've got i gotta go take
a nap thank you for watching
if you really did like this please do
like comment subscribe
share let's talk about all the nerdy
stuff down below i like the nerdy stuff
but if
you know you're into something else we
got a bunch of that too at ep canada
what do you like
do you like um do you like the royals
like something about the royals i don't
know
we got that how about oh i know what
people like anders elba
i like that guy that guy is awesome we
got a video about that guy you should
put one right there that guy should be
in
should be in everything how about dogs
we have anything about dogs like puppy
dogs or something can we do like a
celebrity dog thing here i don't know if
that exists
if that's real or not kate is it is that
real do we have that
she's not here like i said i need to
take a nap